So, let's assume that the array of grades is completely filled. No partially
filled arrays on this question. Can you write a method which returns the sum of
the scores for the ith student? If you're ready to try this for yourself, just
skip to the quiz. If you want to see a smaller example first, keep watching.
What if my grade book looked like this, and I wanted to calculate the total for
Sandra. Sandra is at index i equals one. If this whole array was called grades,
then I would want to add up this cell, which would be grades [1] [0], because
this is the first student. And the zeroth topic would be this spot, because
it's student one and topic one. And grades [1] [2] would be this one, Student
One, Topic Two. To get the sum for this student we would want to add all of
these up. Now, it's your turn. Try coding this in BlueJ. But bare in mind, you
might not know the size of the array up front. There might be a variable for
the number of topics and the number of students.